each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay all right let's get started thank
you very much for coming today it's my
great pleasure to introduce Sheeran
krishnamoorthy who's visiting us from
Brown University for the next couple of
days so the presentation today is about
flapjacks which is an event reactive
model for programming interactive for
each web applications let's welcome sure
thank you it's good to be amongst old
friends new friends all sorts of friends
I would like to start by making sure
that you know i'm a little late thanks
to the microsoft complex as i discovered
they putting the complex in the word
complex so i want to make sure that my
talk finishes on time even if i started
a bit late so it wouldn't be a bad idea
for us to write a little program to make
sure that happens okay so we'll write a
little JavaScript application to do this
many of you I'm sure programmed in java
script for the few most of you patience
for those of you who haven't this will
be a quick introduction to how you
program these sorts of things the nice
thing about javascript is it talks to
HTML you've all they got a webpage you
can you can make that webpage do things
by adding a little bit of scripting to
it so i'm going to write myself a little
div which you can think of as a place
holder called current time where i'm
going to put the time i have a function
that sets the time by going into the div
you see it says get element by ID
current time so it's finding that spot
on the web page and then into that spot
on the web page it's inserting the
current time okay and I have to also
tell the JavaScript that I want to run
this so in my body tag I say here's the
thing that I want you to run on load
which is set time all that make perfect
sense okay so if i run this program why
would then be extremely unhappy
there's a small problem this sorry yeah
there's a small problem here that this
will tell me how much time I have left
and how much time I have left will never
decrease so it's great for me as the
speaker not so good for you as the
audience so in fact perhaps I want a
slightly different program so let's say
I want this kind of looking field so
it's going to tell me how much time is
elapsed and maybe I have a reset button
let's think about how to write that
program so it's a little more
complicated because the amount of
elapsed time is going to keep changing
okay it's going to tell account up from
zero maybe or countdown from some number
all right what does this program look
like well I'm still going to give myself
a placeholder on the screen that says
current time and there's a little blank
hole over there that I want to fill in
I've gotta set some you know variables I
need a timer ID I want to keep track of
how much time has elapsed I have to
start the timer and I use a function
called set interval there's a few
different ways you can do this in
JavaScript that are all roughly the same
and I want to do something every second
so it may be tracks how many seconds
have elapsed and then I have to say what
I want to actually do every second which
in this case is I want to get the
current time incremented by one and
stick it in the web page I need to
remember to start that timer but
remember there was also a reset button
so I create myself a button on the
screen and I give it the ID reset but it
doesn't yet have any behavior so I have
to go write the function that gives it
behavior okay so everybody here has
written a GUI program at some point in
their lives probably many gooey programs
so this style of programming is
extremely familiar to you okay just the
syntax is a little different now we
should just make sure that we understand
what this program is doing right i mean
it's it's just counting up and when i
click reset it starts to start from 0
again the purpose of this program is to
fill that hole over there now how do we
make sure that it's doing this correctly
well it's completely obvious write the
value for that point comes from that
expression over there the value of that
expression comes from elapsed time whose
value is set in the line before it which
happens if i call do every second do I
actually call do every second well yes I
do over here but that's inside some
other function set interval and that
function is actually inside start timer
so it all depends on where the start
timer is being called which thankfully
it is over here but in fact there's more
stuff on
the screen right there's a lapse time
equals zero which may or may not have
some impact well it's pretty obvious
that's the initialization but there's
also another elapsed time is equal to 0
over here which of course is called by
reset the labs which is called by this
function over here okay so we spend 30
years getting rid of spaghetti code and
we've done it very successfully so the
reason about what happens in that little
spot over there I have to think about
timers I think about initialization I
have to think about overlap interference
the structure of callbacks and of course
everybody in this room has spotted the
bug in this program right good okay so
what's happening in these there is one
and you can ask me later on so what's
happening in these programs is that we
have a world out there we're sort of
time keeps continuing downward and we
have a program but the program sort of
isn't always running at some point
something happens in the world an event
loop invokes a callback that callbacks
runs for a little time and it returns a
value back to the world and then after
some point in time again there's another
event the program gets invoked and so on
but the program in some sense isn't
running between these in vacations you
have these separate threads of execution
and it's the responsibility of the
program to figure out how to get values
from one thread of execution to the next
and all these event loops return void in
JavaScript and their return void because
the event loop is not part of the
program right the event loop is kind of
neutral it's agnostic that a program it
doesn't want to know anything about the
program's computation or its values it
says I'm just letting you know something
happened don't tell me anything in
return I don't want to know about it
okay so any communication here is the
responsibility of the developer but
these are all voyage returning functions
so immediately you've lost any notion of
composition any notion of type full
programming has been completely
eradicated furthermore the only way a
void returning function can have any
effect on the world is by having side
effects which is why even the simplest
program has to have side effects and
mutation now you know Eric Myers not in
the room so of course a very clear he'll
tell you why that's a bad thing okay
well he's what Oh Eric okay good so I
want you to think that void
a four-letter word okay it's a bad word
because it means even the simplest
possible program i can no longer reason
about compositionally functionally i can
no longer reason about algebraically i
have to think about state and of course
if you're in a concurrent world state
and concerns you don't exactly interact
nicely but i'm being forced into that
structure by the API now you all know
that I'm really like a scheme guy at
heart some of you at least know that so
you all know that this is really just an
advertisement for scheme right I'm
setting you up so how would I write the
same program in PLT scheme for instance
well it's a lot prettier in my opinion
but unfortunately it's no better because
all these things are callbacks they all
end and send and send us an imperative
operation and the return type of all of
these things is void okay oh that scheme
right it's like a 25 year old language
clearly ready to be put to seed so maybe
we should take a look at a nice modern
language likes a Java well I can't fit
any Java code on the screen the screen
isn't big enough but I don't even need
to look at the code I can just look at
the API documentation right you look at
the API documentation and there's a long
list of voids over there okay so that's
a structural problem with Java also but
maybe it's just scheme in Java and maybe
we should go to like you know good
French programming language nice
stateful programming language like Oh
camel well do camera guys are clever
they don't call it void they have a
different four letter word called unit
instead okay but that's no better but
it's obvious that you know all along
garrick were here he'd say we looking at
Haskell right well what does Haskell do
Haskell is really clever Haskell doesn't
even use four letters instead it uses
two letters and two other characters but
as four characters all the same ok so
even Haskell which rents on and on about
functional structural recursive
algebraic programming with rich types
can't seem to figure out what to do
about basic stuff like gooeys even the
simplest GUI in Pascal has the same
problem you've introduced the IO monad
this pollutes your program back to
square one so what's happening in these
programs is that there's something
peculiar about the flow of control of
interactive applications the programs in
some sense don't run ok they wait for
something to happen in the world and
some event maybe it's a keystroke or
maybe
stock deck or some event happens that
event comes through the model which then
propagates out to all the devices which
may in turn cause for the flow of
control to happen but the important
thing in all these cases is that the
program is not in control it's the world
that's in charge and all that the
program is doing is essentially
listening to the sounds of the universe
right it's waiting for something to
happen waiting to be told to do
something and reacting and all these
route all these ap is that have shown
you all these return types of void are
simply a symptom of that problem so it's
worth it for us to think about whether
instead of shoehorning our existing
languages into these programming
frameworks maybe we should ask what are
the principles of programming in this
style in the first place okay especially
since more and more of our programs are
of this form okay so I want to think
about language support for interactive
applications I've done a bunch of stuff
over the past several years on
synchronous web programming using
continuations and various other things
where we sort of solve this problem
there and we felt pretty good about
ourselves until of course Ajax came
along and ruined everything for us again
so it just means you know we get to do
more research that's good okay so let's
think for a moment from first principles
about what information we're getting
from the world remember the program
sitting waiting for the world to tell it
things well the world says things like
here's a current position of the mouse
maybe the mouse move it might say here
are some key strokes that you got and
here's the sequence of keystrokes that
you received or it might be things like
here's the user location of your
programming cell phones as we are these
days it might be a sequence of ajax
responses coming back from a server it
might be mode keys it might be mouse
clicks it might even be as we've seen
what the current time is now of course
I've yeah I've employed a rhetorical
device you're of arranging these things
in a very particular way and as you can
see i talked about current things and
sequences of things okay and it's useful
to have the dichotomy because current
things always have a value but the value
may keep changing even as you're looking
at it it might keep changing the current
time for example okay and sequences of
things are discrete you know the mouse
is clicked once and that click takes
infinitesimally small period of time
right I mean you sort of can't even ask
when it happened but it's discrete there
may be an infinite number of them you
don't know when the
first one happens you don't know if a
first one happens and you don't know
when the next one will happen so these
are really two very different kinds of
beasts you've already seen examples of
these in the simple program I've shown
you because over here that is one of
those continuous things right it's
always changing its always got a value
that's one of those discrete things you
don't know if recent will be clicked you
don't know when it'll be clicked ok now
this is an idea that I'm borrowing from
functional reactive programming a lot of
what I'm talking about is trying to
build and sort of trying to make
practical this idea that's been floating
around in the programming languages
community and is somewhat sort of an
obscure space in the pl community it's
great work but we're trying to we're
trying to sort of use it to build lots
of real-world applications ok so these
things are called for peculiar reasons
behaviors and event streams so if you
ever CB o-- capital B right this is my
Hungarian coding notation if you ever
see a capital B it means one of these
current things think like a timer and if
you ever see a capital e it means one of
these potentially infinite sequences of
events all right make sense Sobeys and
ease good see why they don't you fight
where the current one is just the first
element of this infinite sequence right
ah so there are in fact almost duels of
each other ok and many and an
implementation will try to exploit that
duality they're not exact the rules of
each other because duplicate events here
matter where it's duplicates if I
converted this into that the duplicates
would not be visible right and again
this doesn't have an initial value that
has an initial value but other than
those small algebraic differences there
almost duels of each other good all
right so the important thing is of
course these things already exists right
javascript has them and you know o camel
has them in Java has them in c-sharp has
them but the important thing is when
something changes that is either the
current value changes or a new event
appears the important thing is we want
all dependencies to update automatically
that is we want to make keeping things
synchronized keeping things consistent
the problem of the language rather than
the problem of the programmer all right
so i'm going to show you two languages
where this happens one language is
something called father time and i want
you to think of it as scheme that
behaves funny all right so here is
father time
and it's running inside dr. scheme which
is a programming environment and
standard scheme expressions just going
to work okay they look exactly like they
do in scheme you write a functional
expression and scheme and it has exactly
the same value as it as it should in
scheme and in fact that's by definition
you can even ask for something like the
current time and it comes back with a
constant right the current seconds is
some number that is the current seconds
of course even as it appears on the
screen it's already out of date but
that's your problem if instead I ask for
something called seconds in father time
I get something that's rather different
okay and this is a honest-to-goodness
value but it's a value whose value keeps
changing in fact I can do things with
seconds right or or I could even do
something like an expression like this
and as you can see I can nest as far as
I want to it's the languages
responsibility to keep the overall
expression up to date not the
programmers ok so I'm writing what looks
like just a functional dependency but
the value keeps updating because it's
the languages responsibility so there
are several important ideas in duck in
father time that I'm not really planning
to talk about in this talk one is this
incremental read eval print loop right
just like you see having a language like
scheme or ml actually works even with
these values we have a systematic way of
taking all libraries and particular GUI
libraries and converting them into these
reactive interfaces so for example we
took like a hundred thousand line GUI
library and what about four hundred
lines of code we get a reactive
interface so you can program it
functionally and we have lots of
optimizations and a very nice
implementation strategy that reuses
existing call-by-value languages okay
there's a bunch of papers and stuff on
this what I want to do is instead of
talk about these ideas I want to tell
you about a slightly different language
called flapjacks which is essentially
the same thing though it's JavaScript
that behaves funny okay so let's see
that timer program we talked about at
the beginning of the talk written in
flapjacks here's what it looks like so
just like I have seconds in father time
I have something called now B which is
the current time it's a B which means
it's a one of these things that always
has a value so graphically you can think
of it as being something like this right
it's always got a value but the value
keeps changing I can also say take some
element in the in the webpage any Dom
element and turn it into an event stream
so give me take the reset event reset
Dom element take all of its clicks and
turn it into an event stream so
graphically looks like this something
nothing happens being click happens
nothing happens for a while pinging
another click happens okay now what I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to get from
here to over here that's the answer that
I'm trying to compute right that's the
elapsed time since the last reset how do
I get there well I want to know what
time each of those clicks happened at
that is I want to take a snapshot of the
value of now be whenever a click happens
well so i take the previous expression
and it's a snapshot the value of now be
if i don't snap sharted remember it's
always going to be kept up-to-date
automatically so I have to say right now
halt computation for this instant tell
me what its value is and remember that
value okay so if your functional
programmer that's a kind of map right
I'm just mapping over this event stream
but i really want to turn it into this
right i want to turn it into a behavior
i want to turn into something that
remembers its last value well so starts
with is an operation that says give me
an initial value which is some starting
time okay in this case maybe 12 was the
starting time and hold on to the value
you asked whether these could be
interconverted starts with is exactly
one of those inter converters okay
starts with says hold on to this value
till it changes then hold on to that
value till the changes then hold on to
that value till it changes and so on ok
now this final expression is just the
difference between those two expressions
it's just algebra and I can send this to
some show time so the point is short
time can just be some arbitrary
JavaScript function it doesn't need to
be in any distractive stuff it's just
getting a value and whatever whenever it
gets a value it gets pushed a new value
it just updates it on the screen okay so
every time now be changes
it pushes a value to all the dependent
expressions which also update which
pushes a value to all of its dependent
expressions was also update and if one
of those happens to be on the screen
you're just going to see the change on
the screen automatically okay yes taste
the event stream and it tells you when
to evaluate its argument click had no
information other than the fact declared
occurred exactly it was a key click with
it it actually does have a little more
information the so it does actually tell
you which key got clicked whatever
javascript is going to give you whatever
event object javascript is going to give
you is actually available but I'm
choosing to ignore it I could use that
as a separate argument snapshot yes so
there's some disc rotation going on yeah
it's not clear how you're doing so
obviously it looks like you're you're
creating a new value every second but
weird where is that captured it is it
every millisecond is it oh so that's a
function so the event the evaluation
model is completely pushed driven so if
I so now be in this case happens to be
defined over a millisecond timer but
it's whenever the timer creates signals
a change that's my touch my unit of
discretization ok so I'm dependent on
whatever discretization is already in
the system you get multiple things
generating things with different ah yes
good so in fact there's an important
property in the evaluation model which I
have I'm not going to talk about in this
talk but I could explain later which is
something that we call glitch freedom
which says you never see things that are
inconsistent you never get a value
that's not consistent with the
expressions you have in your program
okay so in this case for example if you
have two different timers they actually
come from the same timer right
essentially you have some time or that's
pushing in two different directions and
coming back together you're guaranteed
that the value you get there is in fact
the functional value you get from these
two different expressions okay and
that's an important semantic guarantee
so one of the important parts of what we
did in father time was to provide that
semantic guarantee that you really get
what your expressions say okay and a
naive implementation will not give you
that so
there's a bunch of things I could say
there but yeah not i'm not going to say
that in this talk okay so just to
summarize this expression this is the
expression i take now be I take this
event stream I converted their behavior
say what it starts with and the thing I
like about an expression like this is
I've turned time which is an input well
that's fine that's just an input but you
don't think normally of buttons as being
inputs you think of them as actors or
actions you don't think of them as
values but I've turned the button into a
value so this whole expression gives me
a value for the button and I can just
think of it as a value that I'm
computing with and I pass it to a
function so I'm back to writing
expressions that look like functions of
inputs and independent of the fact that
these happen to be highly reactive and
changing and so on okay so that's an
important detail about the way about the
programming style that this language
engenders alright so we've built a bunch
of applications with this we've had
several people build third-party
applications we built several working
applications that people actually use so
if something goes wrong my reputations
at stake yes maybe you get to this later
I didn't see how the event stream water
solves the problem of dependencies that
you are unit to the first you had these
complex dependencies among different
paths of their well so this is the whole
program it sent I mean there's a small
there's a little bit missing but this is
essentially the whole program right so
the dependency between the button and
the value of the button is expressed in
this expression so I straight answer
your question right here with the screen
okay so the point is I'm not I'm there
is a timer hidden underneath here okay
but I'm giving you a completely
different way of writing that program
I'm not telling you how to massage that
program a little bit I'm giving you a
totally different model for writing that
program which is to think of all the
expressions as being pure expressions
writing functional compositions of those
expressions so where does that break
down you remember the first slide I
showed you was just a really dumb
program in java script that put the
screw a value on the screen and I said
what's wrong with this and as you
rightly point out it only presents a
value once okay so what I'm asking you
to do is think in terms of the program
running once right
but if you now change some of the sub
expressions to actually be things that
run many times it becomes the languages
problem to rerun the program for you
many times that's the model I'm
presenting here okay a lot of complexity
gets buried in the language so things
like the optimizations and so on do
become relevant yeah yes surviving so
some ways it's a familiar model in the
sense it when you have an Excel
spreadsheet absolutely absolutely
propagator exactly exactly i don't know
if there's a way to update a cell every
second i'm sure they're probably today
it must be sure there's something
anything you can do that the excel
rewriter then picks up on but i'm also
giving you a sort of all the benefits of
higher-order functional programming that
but but yes yeah it's it spreadsheets
and as you'll see it's spreadsheets
extended up to mashups and so forth okay
yes so you said to give you immolation
models of their look both ways yeah in
the Saved economy i'll go back to the
same example if you cover your vendor
another one yeah there's really no need
to compute up anything on the list of it
um it's only yes windows appears again
that you want to there's a complex
argument in both directions you're right
okay so yes you could view it that's a
perfectly reasonable thing you could if
you wanted to add another event over
here that said am I visible and
visibility would be another event that
triggers computation and then you won't
be computing if it weren't visible with
the push model on the push model has the
advantage that I don't have to pick a
polling frequency well yes yes yes yes
yes is goodness good okay okay so there
are several applications but what I want
to do is you know your programmers well
your researchers but you might even
write programs actually you guys do
write programs right do you have to
write your own code so that's nice thing
about talking at a lab um I want to give
you a feel for what it's like the
program in this language I don't want to
talk about the theory of it you know
there's papers for that I want to give
you a feel for writing actual programs
writing abstractions okay so let's start
with a very simple abstraction that I
I've pulled out so i'm not going to show
you the whole applications i'm just
going to show you some little snippets
and this is an example that shows up
repeatedly in the systems that we build
but since you haven't used our systems
here's one that you have well maybe not
in this room but you've heard of
something called google it's a company
out in California and they build this
thing called google mail okay wherever I
say Google you should hear windows live
or buzzes or what's it called a Bing
right okay so they imagine this big male
okay all right so in your mail program
that's web-based what you really like is
an autosave buffer so as you keep typing
here periodically the content gets saved
onto the server so if your browser dies
you don't lose your content okay good so
I want to build an abstraction like this
because it turns out autosave buffers
are useful for everything they useful
over here they are useful in conference
reviews you don't want to lose those
either they're useful in job searches
they're useful in various in a wiki's
and so on so let's build this autosave
abstraction and by the way notice it
also does things like tells you when it
was saved and so on you might also have
some styling that says you know print do
something to the background when it's an
unsaved state etc okay so let's write
this but widget so I want to create a
widget I want to put it in the library
so I can read
lots of applications so let's say it's
called make save box so obviously needs
to create some kind of text area that I
can type into okay so we'll call that
doc and maybe every 60 seconds it's
going to set out some timer to go off
and save this thing and it returns
document okay perfectly sensible there's
one short coming with this right what if
you want to say one a different
frequency well you don't want to save 60
seconds maybe you want to make that a
parameter so we'll make that a parameter
okay of tea but is that the only reason
why you might want to autosave because
the timer relapsed are there other
reasons you might want to auto save save
save now I think okay so almost as if
you were planted ok so somebody click
save now and you want to say if then
also all right so maybe we should add a
second parameter that takes the power
button into account as well okay um so
there's our thing right it's either
every T seconds or when button clicks
but i'm actually using english on
purpose because not entirely clear what
I want this to be right there are other
possible definitions it's like maybe
when the button clicks or if T seconds
of the lab since the button it clicked
or maybe it's like when T seconds and
button clicks or it's after every
keystroke or maybe I want to do
something if nothing changes or maybe I
don't want to do something of nothing
changes there's you know so clearly it's
obvious that i need to add about four or
five more parameters right and that's
when you go read your perlis epigrams
right and pearl is as if your procedure
with 10 parameters probably miss them so
how can we present a better abstraction
well to me there's actually an obvious
abstraction here it's an event stream
okay you want to pass in an event stream
and say you save every time the event
stream fires and I can then pass in
different kinds of events dreams I can
pass in a timer that says you know fire
every 60 seconds I could pass in
something that says every time the box
is clicked or I could merge those two
streams right to say every time the box
is clicked or the timer fires or more
complex compositions so this is where
now having a good rich programming
language a little richer than Excel
perhaps a rich programming language in
the ability to write Combinator's the
ability to merge these events dreams
becomes really useful because I've now
achieved something
that's a very valuable separation in
computer science it's the separation
between mechanism which goes inside and
policy which comes from the outside and
all these are representations of
policies yes urge to streams yes what is
it what are the elements that you get it
seems like there's a type fishing oh
yeah there is oh yeah yeah it's
JavaScript man yeah until about I don't
know 1225 tomorrow I won't have to worry
about this question so ya know there is
and in this particular case so so the
question is what do you actually need
out of this event stream of all you're
treating it as a policy you don't
actually care about the content of it at
all okay so that's why I can ignore that
question here yeah um in fact in so we
so just to give you a quick preview of
what I'm talking tomorrow about a type
system for JavaScript and we can type
all of these programs so here for
example the types would be very simple
because they would say all I expect is
that it's an event stream okay and if
the mechanism try to inspect the values
the event stream obviously will be in
trouble right so this particular one
it's just an event stream so i give this
nice policy mechanism separation and a
useful way of thinking about how to
structure this program and in fact a
structure all of these sorts of
abstractions which is use event streams
to represent policies don't do too much
in the mechanism itself now of course
what I've done is I've shown you how to
fire events but I haven't told you
anything about how to save something on
a server well so you know in web
programming its standard to think about
the server as being the place where
persistence is done in our reference
monitoring access control and so on and
you just send requests and get responses
right and you have primitives in
JavaScript for doing this so we have a
primitive engine flapjacks called get
web service object e4 unruh bleah
unwieldy name but i'll abbreviate it in
the talk but the important thing is get
web service object key takes a stream of
requests and returns a stream of
responses so I want you to think of
earlier I said I want you to think of a
function as being written once but
running every time as many times as
necessary this is the same sort of thing
I want you to think of the server is
something you contact once and get one
response from but then it's the
languages job to lift that to being
something that takes a stream of
requests and it returns a stream of
responses okay
so once i have get web service object e
it's pretty easy that all i do is i have
these requests and when ii was the merge
of those two streams well it's I'm sorry
it's the argument which was coming in
maybe as a merge I snapshot the value of
doc I have to snap shot it because i
want that instantaneous value and i have
some i have a make requests function
that construct some javascript object
with descriptors urls and you know all
the usual stuff that the server is
expecting to hear and i passed that
stream to get web service object II and
I get back a stream of responses ok so
that is how i do the saving but i might
want to do more i might want to also
style it so for example we like to draw
a little back we'd like to change the
border color of the box between saves
and between the sending of a save and
the acknowledgement of a safe yeah any
this feels like as a flavor of startling
information machine in the sense that
you have these values that are single
variables that have been like a few
similar values inside like what happens
if you wanted to do in a statement on
the return value of what are these
things to you just say if safety equals
something or do you have to do dollar be
of safe how about we look at the next
life that's so perfect setup almost
perfect server i'm not going to do quite
an if but you'll see how so exactly the
sort of thing you're talking about might
get addressed ok so after the next slide
we'll get back to your question so for
example I want to do styling right I
want to say depending on the state of
the box I want to change the way the box
appears so I have safety that I have
right now I also pull out all the
changes right so every time this dock
thing changes I have an event stream for
that I now transform changes with the
constant unsaved i chant i transform the
saved responses with the constant saved
and i merge those two so now i get an
event stream that might look like
unsaved unsaved on save done saved saved
unsaved unsaved unsay it saved unsafe
done saved saved ok so every keystroke
basically this one keeps getting to
unsaved every time the server responds
it comes back
says saved well I turned that into a
behavior it start being all the empty
buffers let's consider it saved okay so
transformed the behavior I can now use
this behavior to style the border color
or style the content or style whatever I
want okay so I don't yeah the Soviets
perfectly what if the server is
unreachable or you drop your connection
or it gives you a responsibility I
actually deleted about seven slides last
night about how we have no fault
tolerance so we have a set of primitives
for doing some doing fault tolerance for
Ajax applications essentially the idea
is you can use continuations and do
replay techniques right and you can
integrate that with flapjacks and I felt
the talk was going too long so i deleted
all of that so but but yes that's that's
an extremely legit and in particular if
we're going to program on a distributed
setting we absolutely have to think
about that yeah I'll get you a question
a moment and I don't know how much this
helps with your question I want you to
think of these as point-wise operators
but sometimes you might want to collapse
them so you might want to have an
accumulator you might want to run a
filter any of those things right but you
never say if saved e you do things point
wise this is 0 this India you never
well starlets have the ability sort of
flat space into single Valerie's they
fit us right so you could you could do
things like Maps or accumulators you
have to be careful about defining what
it means to collapse right because these
are infinite streams so yeah yes if I
understand the semantics of this program
correctly then when the water change is
to indicate that it can say it's not
necessary the text that you see on the
screen that has been saved because
you're actually looking at an outdated
response that's exactly right take your
time faster that's exactly right and in
fact you could say you could take this
program and make it more complicated to
that I actually um no because ya know
that's right that's right that's right
that's right reason it's it that's
correct see it in this case means save
recently and I would have to define
something a little more complicated to
say saved and not changed since then
yeah okay good okay so let's now try to
write you know the web talks I've got to
say something about pipes and tubes
somewhere in there so let's say that
what I want to do is I want to set up a
little thing where you can type in text
and the text you set you type is a
search string that sent to Flickr and it
pulls out all the images that are
available against that search string and
sends it back which you now display on
the page ok so again I'm going to assume
that I have some JavaScript functions
that take a string and turn it into a
request and take the response and turn
to a list of URLs so this is marshaling
and on marshaling right this is just
parsing stuff so I set up a box search
box pull out the event stream of queries
that sticks that gets typed into it I
then map it to turn it into a set of
requests as you can guess i'm going to
send that request off with get web
service object e I'm then going to map
the responses with this other pure
function or some JavaScript function and
if i start with the empty list then what
it's saying is the empty box corresponds
to the empty list of responses as i keep
typing i get new list of responses and
finally i can put that into my web page
by just inserting it into some
development called thumps ok so again
i'm doing functional programming but
what it's telling me is that every time
search changes query is going to update
every time that updates request e is
going to update
whenever that updates response be is
going to update and every time that
updates the content on the screen is
going to update okay so all I'm doing is
showing you the same primitives I've
shown you before to construct a fairly
different application but there's
something really annoying about this
application what's really annoying is
that every single keystroke I type this
thing is going to go off and send
something off to the web right and
that's bad that's really annoying I mean
you know webs webs not really free right
so in fact the programs that we write
look just a little different we use
something called convey and comi is a
Combinator that says don't bother about
any events during this period during
this duration so in this case wait for a
second so let this person keep typing
and wait for a second and when there's a
second pause then do something okay so
drop events till then and filter out the
events and this is a really useful
primitive for all sorts of user
interactions because you want to avoid
things happening to miss too quickly on
screen so comedy shows up all over the
place okay and so one of the things I
could do is I could actually use
something like call me to clean up some
of the behavior i showed in the previous
slide for instance all right another
thing you can do is take user interface
content and behavioral content and
package them up nicely now this was
supposed to be what object oriented
programming did but sort of tends to do
pretty poorly and the whole call back
style reveals where that weakness is
where that falls apart right because you
have all these weird control flows
between components that aren't properly
localized so here is resume this is a
job search manager that several computer
science departments use and these aren't
real candidates don't worry and over
there you see that there's little filter
applicants box and if I click on it I
get a box that looks like this so
there's all sorts of criteria that you
can filter applicants using so I want to
show you a little bit about how this
component of resume is written so I have
a function let's say called pick gender
it should be sex but we're Americans we
don't use such words okay so i have a
user interface component which in this
case is a selection box that has two
values either male or female and i'm
going to return a package of two things
a dom component component which is the
UI
the predicate which is pretty obviously
take the value out of the UI so here
lexical scope does the right thing right
take the current value of this compare
it against person gender for whoever the
person is and give me back a boolean
okay so that's a filter I can also have
a different filter that maybe is a score
and I have a textbox and I can do
various styling for the text box to make
sure that that's the way I want it to be
and I can have a checker for that and
now these are functions that i can use
directly right so i can take one of
these things and separately pull out the
UI component and put it on the screen
and the dot the dom component to put it
on screen and the print component use it
as a filter if for example i apply this
function using filter to a list of
applicants every time somebody types
something different over there
automatically my list of applicants
filters so anybody here who's used
itunes knows you have a little box up in
itunes and as you keep typing text the
content down here keeps changing
automatically you don't have to press
return and so on and that's exactly the
behavior you get for free by using this
but in fact you also want to combine
filters so for example you have a list
of filters and there's a function that
says tell me which filter you want so I
create an option that says what the
filter options are a selection box for
that and some filter is just take this
selection look up the corresponding
filter and that gives me back the
specific selected sub filter and what am
I going to return again a filter so the
DOM is just a span that says here's the
filter you selected and here is the Dom
for that filter so if you select this
kind of filter you get one kind of
search box you select a different filter
you get a different kind of search box
and the predicate is just the sub
filters predicate then we have
combinators over these the usual land
and or Combinator's and that's how we
compose that big filter box that you saw
so it truly is this is literally the
kind of code that's running that there's
no tricks there's no sort of weird
imperative d underneath right this is
the code that's running and you can
compose these two big build bigger and
bigger filters finally let me show you a
sort of mash up like example so in this
case I'm going to take a Twitter and
Google Maps so Twitter is
you know Twitter had people say random
stuff on the web and they put out these
things called tweets and there's a
public twitter stream that you can get
from Twitter of all the tweets that
people are saying in the world okay good
don't ask I'd yeah and I might want to
mash this up with you know Google Maps
or live maps or something to show where
all these things are being set right
just to waste even more time so for
example I went last night and they know
I started the program and the third
thing I got was you know there's
something in Boston is clearly kind of
hungry and then you know a few tweets
later somebody's wishing somebody else
good morning so as these tweets keep
appearing I want them to keep displaying
them on the screen and maybe when i
click on the button i want to get the
text not going to show you all the code
here but i want you to understand that
there's an interesting principle the
principle is that this is a name of a
function from the google maps api okay
and you can see my callback principle
being illustrated nicely so you give it
a string that says you know like you
know providence rhode island bangalore
india whatever you give it a string and
it comes back and gives you the geocoded
location for that string if it's able to
succeed okay so there's a function of
this form what we do is we take
functions like this and systematically
transform them into functions of this
sort okay we make them type full
basically I'm not going to tell you how
we do it and it's actually a little
challenging so if you're really
following along the talk you might want
to think about how you might be able to
write such a transformer there's one
piece you're actually slightly missing
and you should ask me about it if you're
interested but the point is this is
something that we can do is
systematically and we do it one time so
now we have a way of getting events true
I have a way of getting a geocode ER
that takes an event stream of locations
and gives me back an event stream of
geocodes so I guess point should have
been geocode so I have that function I'm
actually going to give you a slightly
different function it's also key on a
carry some additional data if I need to
so take some additional data and gives
me back that additional data just pass
it through polymorphic link so i can
overlay additional information beyond
just the location such as the tweet okay
and similarly i'm going to get a get
twitter pub tweet so take twitter's api
and turn it into an event
stream and also a map overlay which is
taken event stream and overlaid on the
map okay it's now I've got events dreams
everywhere so I get the tweets I map
this function over here that basically
takes the tweet passes it to Google and
gets back the geocode for that tweet
right so this is just the transformation
from the from the Twitter information to
the Google information and now I have to
filter out all the ones that came back
with faults because sometimes you give
it the name of a string and it says I
don't know where this place is because
Twitter is not giving it quite the right
information you filter those out and
your overlay it on the map so this is
really sort of really you want to think
of it as classic unique style shell
programming right except I can do this
also for mashups all right so what I'm
trying to do is give you a feel for what
it's like to be a programmer in this
language you think functionally but you
get some of you get all the benefits the
sort of object oriented programming and
subtyping and so on that work in just
the right way and most of all you get
the right water essentially functional
specifications that say here's the
one-time behavior of what I want and if
something changes make the language do
it for me so I'm going to leave you with
one more abstraction and this 1 i'm not
going to show you any code at all
because i really want you to think of it
as a challenge ok so the dom as i told
you provides events it tells you about
you know mouse ups and clicks and so on
and every programming language api right
c-sharp comes with a bunch of things
visual basic comes with a bunch of
things but it doesn't give you Complex
events right it has a bunch of primitive
events and that's all you get so for
example it doesn't give you drag and
drop as an event but that's a reasonable
thing to think about in fact it's a
reasonable thing to wear it because
yours used in all sorts of contexts when
you're building gooeys for instance if i
drag over there and drop I mean I want
to move the buffer I'll move the window
if I drag over there and drop then what
I'm saying is I want to resize something
or if I drag over there and drop then
what I'm really saying is I want to
select something so if you're building a
GUI that has these kinds of operations
it's really useful to be able to think
of
drag-and-drop is a primitive and then
you can ask contextual questions about
where you were dragging and where you
were dropping to figure out how to
interpret this right and you might even
want to do different interpretations
depending upon other circumstances so
the challenge for you if you have a
programming language a favorite language
is how would you encapsulate this as a
events of some sort whatever the event
encapsulation of your language is and if
you're curious about how we do it in
flapjacks we have a section on this in
our paper and we show how to get this as
a honest-to-goodness abstraction so you
can say here's a drag-and-drop event
stream it's actually so speaking of your
question about types it's an alternation
of drag events and drop events but it's
still an event stream okay and we can
actually then write a whole bunch of
functions think of it as like a visit
you get this visitor kind of kind of
abstraction right you get a type and
then you can write functions against
that type here you get a event stream
and you can write lots of different
functions that plug into that event
stream so it's you know giving you back
that functional abstraction capability
all right good so this is actually a
little complex which is the real reason
I'm not showing you the code I'd love to
whatever take about three pages and
that's too much code alright so I want
to start wrapping up what I've said in
this talk I one of the nice things
that's happening is other people are
beginning to realize there's value of
thinking about the internet as
communications of events dreams opera
actually published this API it's not a
very good API so it hasn't really caught
on but I think over time where people
who build web servers are sooner or
later going to start wanting to publish
better API isn't they do and in a way
they already know if you think about our
atom feeds and RSS feeds and so on
they're getting at this idea they just
haven't sort of sat down and formalized
exactly what they mean ok so the world
already thinks this way in fact if you
think about these behaviors if you've
programmed in java script you already
have a behavior even if you don't
program in flapjacks it's called the dom
because we think about the dom any
change i make to the dom automatically
gets propagated to the page i don't have
to make a change and then notify
somebody to then go off and do the
update anything i do to the dom is
automatically propagated out without any
additional effort ok so you can think of
flapjacks is saying well why is it that
only the dom is this privileged data
structure that gets
capability why not whole bunch of layers
that get this capability pushing all the
way through and ending at the Dom that's
one way to think about what we're doing
is generalizing that principle yes what
characterization were you doing is
you're taking time as a dimension and
you're making it explicit things are
changing through these events or
whatever and your abstraction is exposed
to that so every slice of time you know
you're doing things it's Calvin you
compose and we gives you this
compositionality um what it doesn't give
you is the simplicity of reasoning about
just one state change I mean in other
words you lose the ability to think
about a single you know I go from this
to that we've got respond to a single
event too I have to think about the fact
that now I have a stream of these things
and everything I do has to deal with the
stream so so I think it's great i mean
i'm really excited about the idea that
you can get this expression i think one
of the barriers to acceptance is going
to be this kind of change of thinking
not just about single you know it's just
like sequential program function i think
your apps on your oh do you always think
about Max and higher-order functions
right you know most programmers think
about you I make this change in it i
change this one variable yes yes so i
guess it's a very similar kind of bug I
think you're right in fact what happens
is as I've actually gone through this
exercise several times of trying to
write a program in a completely standard
JavaScript style and then slowly
transform it into flapjack so one of the
weird things about flapjacks is we
offered as both a sort of language that
does some of the stuff for you
automatically but also as a library so
you can just program in java script with
this as an extra library ok or dumb what
do they call them kits I guess so
there's some terms and javascript
performance like you so anyway so I've
gone through that experience and it is
actually not completely trivial even for
me with my experience to do that because
what it's doing is it's forcing me to
say it was really easy to write this one
step okay but then as you say but the
problem is then I don't know what my
sort of long-term behavior is and in
fact I get horribly confused because it
doesn't seem to be exactly what I
expected it to be so in some sense what
I'm doing and we have the same
experience of continuation based web
programming is we said we're going to
put a slightly greater burden on the
programmer but what it does is it
reduces the burden on all sorts of
downstream tools
so verification tools program in l so we
built a model checker we built program
analyses and so on for for our web
application framework and it became a
lot lot lot easier because we made the
programmer do this little bit of extra
effort right off not just sort of
sticking everything in a string and
saying okay I'm done and then when I
have to restart I'll figure out how to
pull all of my data back and maybe it's
not there maybe I don't know what's
really going on right so it's the same
way reasoning about this say where the
theorem prover is much easier because
you re you can do this sort of
functional reasoning but it does push
the burden onto the programmer and
that's not always that's not always a
popular thing yeah yes yeah one of the
nice things about the doll is that it's
one data structure then persist across
multiple invitations of JavaScript
protein so that even if one of them
faves you still can go back to the dawn
and you know do something acceptable
well what you are saying is no your
entire core has a sort of semi
persistent property so as a programmer I
would think it you know the burden of
ensuring that nothing fair use is much
higher in this case you agree ha I well
I'm not sure that that's necessarily
true ah because if I have some time if I
have some behavior attached to a timer
say okay I've got some timer that's
running over there and let's just say
that I happen to have an error in my
function that stash to the timer the
next time the timer far is that function
is going to be called again okay so i
might have some piece of code here that
has errored out in fact i argue part of
the problem with javascript is that
weird things happen right little pieces
of code error out and other piece of
code just continued happily running
right even though the world may be in an
inconsistent state so I think we're at
least in a better position to say this
is running against an inconsistent state
because there's some expectation of what
the state was supposed to be it's as
property i said that the expression is
the value is always can be computed
simply from the functional expressions
so these we have a chance of saying the
world is running but it's an
inconsistent state and you might want to
be aware that the output you're getting
doesn't quite make sense in contrast to
traditional JavaScript where you run
your program and you've got this web
page and things sort of run and then you
click on a button and nothing
and then you go to the error console I
actually like asking people do you know
where the javascript error console is
it's shocking how many even programmers
have no idea there is an error console
right and you open it up and it turns
out it's like 20,000 like little blue
yellow in our triangles and one red
thing saying there was an error and and
it's some weird property and undefined
and the other thing is JavaScript also
part of this sort of HTML culture of
trying not to make things error out
right it's it's actually hard to get
JavaScript to give you an error like I
mean you can say undefined dots our
method name and it says okay now I
really can't just make up nonsense but
short of that it's pretty hard to get it
to actually stop and say sorry something
went wrong so I'd argue that that is not
such a good thing in the first place and
having some sense of what the state of
the program was supposed to be might
actually save you a little bit there
yeah oh oh I see I see ya reporting
other code and stuff like that you want
to make sure one of them doesn't end up
breaking your pager yeah well but in
that case you would just have had a
whole bunch of separate event streams
right and one of them is broken as long
as you are you know you're in one of
these mashup cases where you have
isolation you're trying to achieve
isolation so you have all these
different mashups that are presumably
presenting event streams okay um you
know you're creating like an iGoogle
kind of page or something like that then
each of these things is printing their
own event stream so the breakage of one
thing completely does not affect another
and in fact I would be able to tell you
that I'd be able to tell you that this
value is a funk you know this is the
cone of influence right or this is the
cone of contribution for a value right
it's all of these expressions so the
error is outside this cone you can be
sure that your value would not have
changed whether that thing ran or not
that's harder to achieve in JavaScript
because you have to do a program
analysis through and dom model to figure
out whether that's true or not so I'd
actually argue that you're making a good
case for this style of programming but
that's a rhetorical point yes seems like
it's possible to end up with
activity Yeah Yeah right send some in so
the worst case is always you're not
touching the doll you a little bit but
it's going to be touching atomic dollars
the damage is this giant and everybody
station mm-hmm so unless you I frame
everything we basically sit back to
square one that's right that's right
that's right another thing is that in
terms of inclusion in the shops yeah
there's also possibility or final denial
of service or some form of things like
that yes you have this superfluously
activity or something that you didn't
really cut right click be reactive
that's right suddenly kind of face off
on you that's right I will not even
begin to pretend that flapjacks is
giving you a handle on getting good web
isolation okay all at all it's doing is
in the case where something is sort of
half broken it can tell you whether or
not that break and brokenness help
affected you okay but the isolation
problem is not this is not solving that
problem i change this size versus you
observe the previous invocation aired oh
yeah iiiii yeah that's right that's
right that's right so in fact we you
know you asked the question about
talking to servers that might be flaky
and that's sort of what happens we have
this retry based model that's
essentially think of it as a
transactional model right so we want to
know which invocation point where we at
which time through the invocation point
in which retry were we on and that way
the server and the client are able to
tell whether our state is synchronized
or not okay so so there's a triple that
basically identifies a unique point in
the computation and each of those
transactions can then be retried
precisely because it says I haven't
heard back here's a timeout policy go do
the reach our computation yeah okay a
few more things I want to say so you
know I keep sort of alluding to
functional programming and you know is
this purely functional well it's a weird
thing because it's functional
programming / imperative values right
and normally that makes no sense except
in our case we're saying it's functional
programming / imperative values but
because the changes are automatically
upgraded updated you don't notice the
fact that the values are imperative but
in fact you can actually introduce
impair rivet II into the program and
I've been doing it from slide 1 because
that's what snapshot does right so
consistency is a primitive but snapshot
says stop evaluation of this little sub
expression I want to know what it was
then as opposed to what it is now so one
question we can ask is should we be
snapshotting by default because that's
what traditional programming languages
do right in fact I would call a variable
as sort of a failed behavior right it's
it says aspiring behavior that never
made it all the way right behaviors are
just variables that don't have this
problem and we've looked at lots of our
code and we find that the number of
snapshots we use is roughly like 125 per
thousand lines of code and this is
actually old numbers as many more
applications now and it seems to be
consistent so you could argue that maybe
you know having snapshot is the explicit
operation rather than update be the
explicit operation um the bug by the way
anyone catch the bug in the initial
slight thing what happens is you
propagate when you click reset it
propagates to the variable but it
doesn't propagate to the screen so you
click reset nothing happens on the
screen till the next time the clock goes
off and then it starts at one rather
than starting at zero precisely because
in some places you need to take that
value and send it to the screen in other
places you forgot to do it okay and I i
must admit by the way that sounds it
sounds like a setup but actually I made
that bug in my program myself and then
said aha good well man so maybe it was
subconscious I don't know so I'll end
with a sort of a purely rhetorical slide
so this is a eric meyer runs the
software radio something something and
he went and interviewed simon baton
jones right so so you're Simon writes a
Simon so I can't do this sort of Simon
accent so I'll just do this my way so
here is the Simon draws this graph right
and he says look there are languages all
right and they're on a spectrum from
useless to useful okay these are these
assignments words not mine okay Simon if
you're there hi and there's all the
other spectrum here from sort of unsafe
to safe okay and so he uses the phrase
this is literally as quote unsafe means
any effects anywhere and safe means very
limited effects or maybe even no effects
ok so he says I'm going to start
plotting languages on this on this graph
now right so you know C and C sharp Java
all of those things start out over there
suppose that looks a little like Mickey
Mouse let's coincidental i guess um and
and now it's simon saying this right
haskell
over here right so in its purest form
right Haskell is like all the way at the
bottom over here it is extremely sore
tough at this corner right it's
extremely safe but I mean you don't even
know if it's running right maybe you put
your hand on the computer see if it gets
warm but even that may not be you know
it does nothing happens ok but this
point is that you know Haskell has been
moving upward that is it's been adding
effects in a very principled way I
actually think Mona is a kind of a
losing proper I I've got lots of issues
with monads but anyway the point is the
haskell community has been moving upward
here but so have those languages they've
been moving sort of to the right right
which is a you know separation logic or
ownership types or any of these things
are basically we're saying completely
unfettered effects everywhere not such a
good thing transactions are also
transactional memory is kind of that
kind of that sort of thing to it saying
maybe if we can think of things in a
little less effect full manner and we
can give the language a little more
ability to reason that would be a good
thing and so a natural question now is
where does flapjacks fit on this slide
well so i'm going to say i sort of
reject this higher or this this this
diagram a little bit because I think
flapjacks I'd say I told you it's a
rhetorical slide I think it belongs
somewhere around here okay because it's
obviously a useful language I mean we
people have built applications with it
even we've built applications with it
but it's it's very much along the sort
of right end of this I mean it would
seem to me that there's some sort of
principal axis over here right and
everything has to be sort of in this
lower left triangle and yet I came
claimed sort of flapjacks is a little
bit outside this triangle and I think
it's because I don't entirely by this
phrase very limited effects I mean it's
not even clear to me why effects are a
bad thing right i mean FX our computer
is actually doing work and making
themselves useful to us so i don't think
that should be considered a totally bad
thing so it's a question of what this
phrase really means is it very limited
effects or should it be maybe limited
observable effects well that's okay too
right observing effects is just seeing
out but that's not a bad thing but maybe
it's something more like limited non
algebraic effects effects that I can't
reason about purely by using algebra and
composition and maybe that's the
problematic thing
and in that circumstance again hat
flapjacks gives you pretty good
algebraic reasoning while still giving
you the ability to write effect full
programs without having to go into sort
of an IO monad or something like that I
don't know and I don't really know
exactly what this picture should look
like so this is more a spur for
conversation than anything else but
before I take questions I just say that
you know somebody else has to do all the
work obviously because I'm you know I
just give talks I I write code occasion
but somebody does rights much more code
than me so these the guys who did it and
in fact leo who's the lead author of
flapjacks is coming here in two weeks to
work with Ben this summer so that's
awesome good choice ok so questions
comments anything else you look like
you're about to say something about that
previous slide yeah I guess um the
characterization was over so what is
your thinking along with in terms of
them the concept of dynamic type does it
mean so you're talking about side
effects right you're not talking about
yes this is probably what side effects
there's not about types at all night and
so a lot of people say guy in types are
a source of inability to reason and also
safety right yeah basically so so it
seems like that's not even a year well
that's that's not in mind well partly
because I was just quoting Simon right
but also um I would claim that static
tight I mean does this difference
between types and safety right c-type
static types are types or syntactic
disciplined right Reynolds always says
this types or a syntactic discipline
that you might run on a program right
safety is a concept of whether you have
abstraction boundaries in your language
and whether the language enforces them
how it enforces them is the
responsibility is you know it's some
combination of factors even in a
statically typed language it's still the
case that not all of them obviously can
be in for statically so that some of
them must be enforced dynamically so in
some sense as scheme programmer is much
closer at least a good scheme
programmers much closer in mentality to
an ml programmer than 2 a.c programmer
right because the scheme programmer
still believes that it's good to have
abstraction boundaries it just so
happens that they're all enforced
completely at runtime and that can
sometimes be problematic ok as opposed
to I don't want abstraction boundaries
or different put differently I have only
one type in the universe and then
there's no abstraction boundaries to
even speak of
right and that type is like the 16-bit
word or something like that right in
fact see I claim is a very peculiar
language even the notion of talking
about soundness of CI claim is a very
strange thing to talk about because
normally when you talk about a soundness
theorem you're starting to say that
there's some static discipline that's
trying to mimic what's happening at
runtime and so I have runtime behavior
that corresponds to it and the soundness
theorem is saying that this accurately
simulates what's happening at one time
okay but that's not how sea works at all
right see actually has to type systems
it's got a static type system that has
things like int and bull and words like
that right but then and the dynamic type
system all it has is like you know 16
bits or 32 bits or 64 bits and you can't
even ask is this thing one of those
things so the notion of soundness is
meaningless because the runtime types
and the static types are totally
disjointed universes so you can't even
call see is not even unsafe right it's
it's something beyond that I'm sorry he
is beyond unsafe right beyond mere
distinctions of safety and unsafe t so I
want to make a distinction in safety and
type type ness and and the other thing
is also there's this worse situation
where you have a static type system but
it's not safe it's not it's not a sound
static type system she's you run this
thing and you think you're getting a
guarantee but you're not right and then
those languages exist too so so I would
claim that we really should separate out
those concepts a little bit but you know
I think static typing is a good thing by
and large and well tomorrow I'll say a
little bit about it even so yeah tascam
elections really the question will see
to it audacious
I love things you're building a building
this language your programming model on
top of a runtime and you don't really
know all that much about that time some
ass this year they're talking about
seconds yeah yeah nothing approaching
given your plan guarantees that you
could absolutely absolutely you know
much about the order you don't know much
about a few other absolutely so with you
I mean in this work that you I don't
know work out some suggestions for a
better set of foreign languages gaps
yeah it's a good question um no because
we're trying to do something sort of
dirty here right it what that's
tomorrow's talk right I would start with
trying to get the static types cleaned
up and then go from there right because
again I need some to get guarantees i
want to be able to talk about static and
dynamic guarantees as part of a
continuum and so that's why we're doing
the type system work right so you're
right i mean even in father time right
technically for the x built on top of
dr. scheme which i should know a lot
about but what is dr. scheme it's like
in all seven hundred thousand lines of
scheme chord another hundred thousand
lines to C++ code so who the hell knows
what these things do right so in some
sense getting any notion it guarantee
out of modern runtime system seems to be
you know slightly wishful thinking I
mean I know it's up there people is a
circle built-in pretty amazing run types
of specifications a bcl are the Java via
de River d it was attempted we're in the
same specification yeah yeah that's
right that's Steven much much much worse
yes well it's also which jobs for prime
time right because there's the
JavaScript runtime there's there's this
five different browsers and each of the
more or less yeah yeah yeah yeah I agree
yeah it would be nice I don't know that
this work has produced much by way of
recommendations other than you know
maybe take the java runtime and
translator person yeah yeah so you know
in case of why it makes and start using
flapjacks to design famous but what if I
wonder you have a big yes some
JavaScript all right so so that's why we
provided as a library right so you can
go in and say I've got this element over
here and I want to make it reactive so I
can attach so what so the library design
is a little careful that way if you say
dollar be and I attach something to an
event stream it leaves the existing
callbacks in place but adds I mean the
implementations all by adding callbacks
to the existing
callbacks right by chaining guarantees
you provide in that game because I do
the outdoors so so flat tax was
intentionally unlike father damn
flapjacks was intentionally designed to
be a compromise a real-world compromise
right so we could say well we would
really we could reject all programs that
are not pure functional with flapjacks
and I think they'll be useless so what
we do provide some ordering guarantees
because if you write something
imperative and you launch a bunch of
events in an imperative sequence we
provide some ordering guarantees there
so that much we have but but we don't
say anything about completely random
code that we can't see and when we could
but I know what to say but we haven't
bothered doing it because I would mean
doing program analysis of JavaScript but
that doesn't exist till tomorrow
afternoon so yeah so visual programming
yeah they tend to because it's what you
can express the graph they tend to come
to the same sir yes yes it's for using
that's right and you thought about well
since that fits making a visual yeah I
mean in some sense that's what Yahoo
pipes is trying to do Diaw who pipes is
a visual language where you can actually
drop events and plug them together and
they've done a lot of work on trying to
be no parce like the 25,000 different
web services out there and so on on it's
still a very discrete model it doesn't
have this notion of behaviors I think we
could it was sort of it would anything
we produced would look shabby compared
to yahoo pipes wouldn't be able to
compete with them right so so in some
sense we're like pipes for textual
programmers yeah yeah
well if I may please please please I
mean I was going to ask you about your
rights as well but there's evaluation
model doesn't seem to be near this you
know so they don't offer any kind of
semantic guarantees with the evaluation
model it's kind of you don't get what
you get with the behavior is whatever
the program run does by running so yes
we could in principle maybe steal the
Yahoo pipes you are high and put father
died you know flapjacks underwritten
that might be a much better alternative
yeah that's true that's true that's true
yeah other questions okay is this
program one of different from the
functional reactive yeah there's several
ways I mean does the evaluation model is
different I mean so so functional
reactive programming is so that's our
underlying inspiration but you know for
example there's no frp work that says
here's how you take an oo library or
some oil primitives and lift them
automatically to a functional world they
haven't even had to think about that and
we provide that as a sort of systematic
thing you can do we also a lot of the
most of the frp world hat work happened
in the context of haskell where you kind
of get event streams for free but they
don't have to think about what what
call-by-value evaluation has to do with
this what we have i think is a severely
clever way of embedding the graph
construction process as a call-by-value
program so we sort of transform your
your program into a call-by-value
program whose execution automatically
builds the graph and then runs the graph
for you so that's sort of a that that's
a pretty big deal because it means that
i can give you the guarantee is certain
guarantees but how this programs
execution matches the underlying
JavaScript execution model or the
underlying scheme execution model that
if I didn't you know if I had to write a
hand interpreter or something I wouldn't
be able to get those kinds of guarantees
so so we're very inspired by it but I
would say we've gone in many different
directions from there call by value
evaluation the push driven model the
object-oriented connections the
optimizations aggrieved on I mean so
part of it is if you do this naively you
know we had a paper where we showed up a
speed up by not percentage but x factor
of 68 okay what that tells you is if you
do this naively it really sucks so it's
pretty easy when you see a factor of
three it's like wow that could be clever
but it's factor 68 you just know the
original was really dumb right so I
can't take too much credit for that but
we've done things like that
all of those are novelties that the
order original frp worked in half yeah
but but you know there they did great
stuff and you know more power to them
yeah yes
very good thank you all for coming yeah
and thank you whoever's out there for
coming